around 1.7 million people are to be
added to the shielding list in
england after experts identified
additional adults
at serious risk of covid19 the list was
expanded after scientists developed a
new tool
to assess whether someone is at risk of
severe disease or death
those identified who are between 19 and
69 years old around
820 000 people will now be prioritized
for
a vaccination our political
correspondent joe pike
joins me now uh a large number of people
being added to the shielding
list joe do we know who they are
we don't yet there are 1.7 million of
them and they should be getting
a letter imminently this is the result
of some oxford university
modeling into the impact of covert on
certain groups the risk of people
having a pretty negative response if
they get the virus up to this point
those people who have been shielding
have often had
a single factor uh contributing to the
fact they are shielding
usually one key underlying condition
such as a
severe respiratory condition or a
certain type of cancer
now this modeling has put together
different factors
a combination of factors so i think
still key
in those people added to the list is
likely to be an underlying condition but
added to that factors such as
age body mass index ethnicity
as well as potentially a postcode if
somebody
lives in an area with high levels of
deprivation
if you are on that list as i say you
should get a letter
imminently if you are under 70 you'll be
prioritized for a vaccine
you should get a vaccine pretty soon
you'll also be asked to shield at home
until the 31st of march and finally if
you are shielding you get the same
support
everyone else already does who is
shielding including
statutory sick pay this is a massive
change though 1.7 million people
added to the 2.2 million already
shielding almost 4 million
in total what it also tells us sarah is
scientists understanding
of this virus and its impact on people's
health is changing fast
and i suppose the government and the
department for health would also argue
that their response is therefore moving
fast as well